it's been a troubled year for the circus
the greatest show on earth the Ringling
Brothers Barnum and Bailey Circus shut
down after a hundred 46 years here in
New York the Big Apple Circus filed for
bankruptcy last year but turns out Big
Apple fans are getting an encore thanks
in part to some last-minute medical help
under the big top in New York's Lincoln
Center the Big Apple Circus is marking
its 40th anniversary but it almost had
nothing to celebrate after declining
ticket sales it filed for bankruptcy
last November then just when the circus
needed a lifeline it found a doctor I
think that to let this disappear would
have been a crime dr. Neil Kahuna vets
and a team of investors bought Big Apple
Circus and a bankruptcy auction and this
holiday season have brought it back to
life there some people are saying you're
saving the circus do you feel that way
no person can single-handedly save the
circus but I think as a group as a Big
Apple Circus family we have saved the
circus what does a surgeon know about
running a circus follow the doctor into
his trailer and you'll find he knows a
lot this is actually the trampoline act
and that's me on the bottom yeah he
spent five years on the road in the
circus life working his way from
trampoline clown to trapeze artist while
he was studying for his medical degree
were you a good trapeze artist no but I
used to tell people I was a greatest
flier in medicine today there aren't a
lot of surgeon trapeze artists that's
why I was the best
there's no exaggerating his credentials
as one of the country's leading spinal
surgeons dr. kahan Yvette's has operated
on three Supreme Court justices that's
actually pretty cool yeah
it was scary but it was cool I could
throw off the balance of the court with
the world what slip of the knife yeah
I've heard that joke before the 68 year
old surgeon was about to retire when the
call came about big a perch
when he agreed to take the job no
surprise he went looking for the best
aerial acts and this year for the first
time ever this is circus history the two
most daring feats in the air are being
done under the same tent the flying
tunisie ah knees are performing the
quadruple somersault on the trapeze and
the fabulous Wallendas are performing
the seven-person pyramid on the high
wire it's risky business in February Nik
Wallenda and his team suffered an
accident in training we were trying to
again up the ante raised the limits we
were doing an eight-person pyramid four
layers high on a wire that was 28 feet
up and unfortunately we began to lose
our balance we don't know why or
particularly what happened five members
hit the ground
his sister Lyanna was most seriously
injured and your sister's doing okay my
sister's doing incredibly well this
happened in February and she's already
back on the wire amazing Melinda says
the circus industry has to start pushing
the limits it hasn't kept up with the
times how do you stay relevant you have
to keep them fascinated there's a lot of
competition out there so these are all
these trailers are all where the
performers live yes in two weeks the Big
Apple Circus will pack up its tent at
Lincoln Center and head for Atlanta and
dr. kahan Yvette's will go with them is
it harder running a circus than you
thought
that's probably
the greatest understatement I've heard
ever I've never worked so hard and so
long in my entire life yeah
this puts medical school to shame so how
does it feel to come back to the circus
after all this time there have been some
moments and and these have been just
recently where I've been able to just
sit and watch the show and realize that
Wow
we did this do you feel like you're
closing a circle for yourself in some
way you know it's not so much the circle
I feel like I'm going home yeah you know
to me it's how many people get to run
away up to service twice but it's it's
nice to be home it's so great that he's
been able to do that again he's a lot of
the aerial performers are trying to
convince him to go up on the trapeze
again and as you might expect his wife
is suggesting that maybe that's not such
a good idea I love what he said there
though it's every kid's dream to run
away with the circus he's done it twice
now it's so great to see that circus
back when the tent was going up in
Lincoln Center this year because I
walked through there on my way home I
was so happy it's it's great but it's
back